bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 4 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette toute
première édition de l'année du 7-8 le
journal je m'associe donc à toute la
rédaction pour vous souhaiter une très
belle année 2016 on commence tout de
suite avec les titres de cette édition
elles ne sont plus 7 mai 12 depuis le
1er janvier cinq communes ont rejoint
saint quentin en yvelines
les compétences de ce nouvel ensemble
officialisée le 9 janvier prochain lors
du conseil d'installation avec quelques
jours de la date anniversaire des
attentats de charlie hebdo et après les
attentats de paris les forces de l'ordre
sont toujours mobilisés julien le cam
secrétaire régional adjoint police
alliance police nationale est l'invité
du journal
nous verrons aussi comment les fêtes de
fin d'année se sont déroulés et la
principale information en ce début
d'année c'est la nouvelle carte des
intercommunalités dans les yvelines
il ya désormais dix regroupements
intercommunaux contre 21 auparavant
parmi les changements importants on
notera que vélizy intègre versailles
grand parc mais surtout que saint
quentin en yvelines compte cinq
nouvelles villes les clayes-sous-bois
plaisir villepreux maurepas et
coignières cinq villes dirigées par des
maires de droite la droite fortement
majoritaire dorénavant michel auger
devrait ont conservé la présidence
l'installation de ce nouveau conseil se
fera le 9 janvier sien et nous avons
voulu savoir ce que vous pensiez de ce
rapprochement de cet élargissement
vos avis avec ce micro-trottoir écoutez
c'est une idée moyenne je dirais c'est
mieux que ce qui était prévu à huit cent
mille habitants je pense qu'on n'a pas
intérêt à faire de trop gros ensemble et
que aller jusqu'au plateau de saclay
avec huit cent mille habitants c'est un
petit peu fou mais c'était une idée du
préfet nos élus ont eu raison de ramener
à quelque chose de plus raisonnable
non mais c'est bien c'est si je pense
que ça peut être une bonne idée d
agrandir si ça permet des structures
tas de choses qui sont nécessaires
est-ce que ça va nous ramener moins
d'impôts ça m'étonnerait je pense pas
bon pour moi ça va rien changer et ben
l'union fait la force
voilà et l'oignon fait la soupe bien
connu non mais je trouve si tu peux en
et plus on est fort plus on est grand
moins il y aura de gâchis et plus
d'efforts seront regroupés jeudi rêve et
sachez que donne dorénavant
saint-quentin-en-yvelines compte 240
mille habitants et l'année a bien
commencé pour arlette et olivier qui ont
connu un réveillon pour le moins
mouvementée leur petite fille leni est
arrivé comme un cadeau du nouvel an dans
la nuit du 1er janvier à l'hôpital du
chesnay
elle fera la joie de son grand frère qui
lui est né un 1er avril
un reportage signé fanny bourdon elle
était attendue dans 15 jours mais elle a
fait une belle surprise à sa maman
arlette qui a perdu les eaux à 20 heures
le soir du réveillon
elle était censée arriver le 19 janvier
elle est arrivée avec trois semaines
pour notre plus grande joie
encore ému arlette n'est pas près
d'oublier cette nuit de la saint
sylvestre
à ce titre la petite leni est le premier
bébé né en 2016 à l'hôpital andré-mignot
au chesnay
elle s'appelle les mi bas comme vous
savez elle est née le 1er janvier à 2h44
donc c'est le premier bébé de l'année
lenny fait la joie de ses parents et de
son grand frère
on leur souhaite une très bonne année
2016 et en cette période de fin d'année
les forces de police sont sur le
qui-vive l'état d'urgence est maintenu
pour en parler nous recevons julien le
camion soir vous êtes le secrétaire
régional adjoint du syndicat alliance
police nationale
alors pour les fêtes de fin d'année les
mesures de sécurité ont été renforcées
l'état d'alerté au maximum
comment cela s'est déroulé si on les
yvelines bah écoutez
et comme vous le dites il y avait une
grande présence policière sur l'ensemble
du département il y avait plus d'une
centaine de policiers de la sécurité
publique mobilisée ce qui représentait à
peu près trente cinq patrouilles sur
l'ensemble du département et on a pu
constater que grâce à l'abnégation et au
professionnalisme des collègues il n'y a
eu aucun événement grave à signaler
est-ce que les effectifs étaient
renforcés justement pour ccta de
vacances scolaires ce qu'on craignait
qu'il y ait des attentats voilà tamment
à noël aussi pour le jour de l'an on
sait que sur le 78 on avait la présence
de quelques sections de crs mais rien de
plus par rapport aux années précédentes
il n'avait pas de d'effectifs
supplémentaires déployés c'étaient les
grands magasins mais également les lieux
de culte qui était voilà justement sous
protection
oui exactement il y avait des lieux de
culte il y avait moins il ya toujours
une également une personnalité qui est
saoul là on va dire sous la
responsabilité la sécurité de la
sécurité publique sur l'asie une
personnalité qui demeurent sur la celle
saint cloud qui prend elle seule une
patrouille qui mobilise à elle seule une
patrouille de police sont donc pas d'un
incident voilà le dit justement n'ont
aucun incident majeur à signaler
voilà quand même eu des véhicules brûlés
mais aucun incident majeur à signaler
justement voilà vous parlez de
vandalisme sur les apartés moyer - voilà
deux voitures lundi deux voitures
brûlées parce que c'est un événement qui
est souvent un frein c'est souvent le
cas justement euros 31 ou aussi à noël
wii u moins de véhicules par rapport au
précédent réveillon - véhicules brûlés
alors ça je vous le dis on doit on doit
certainement enfin on le doit grâce au
professionnalisme
voilà au passage des patrouilles à la
présence de mes collègues sur le terrain
justement là ce sera forcément un
policier a pu éviter des actes comme
celui ci mais savent exactement il ya
une 200 à près de 100 voitures sur les
départements quand même ah non il ya eu
une vingtaine de véhicules
une vingtaine de véhicules de france
alors voilà il ya une vingtaine de
véhicules de de brûler sur le
département
le 31 décembre votre syndic a diffusé un
communiqué pour dénoncer le laxisme dont
les yvelines que dénoncer vous de quoi
était-il question alors effectivement
mes collègues de la bac versailles ont
eu affaire en
en l'espace de deux mois à des
situations violentes notamment le
lendemain des événements du 13 novembre
donc le 14 novembre
un collègue delà de la bac de versailles
qui a été frappé au visage un est blessé
l'individu interpellé a été une un
rappel à la loi un simple rappel à la
loi
1 nous dénonçons sign outre onze ans
cette décision scandaleuse
c'est un signal c'est un signal
scandaleux qui est qui est donné à mes
collègues comment les magistrats enfin
on vous en expliquer cette situation
justifiait peut-être moi je ne sais pas
mais effectivement nous on fait le
constat que les sanctions ne sont pas
assez sévères
un alliance police nationale nous
dénonçons en fait nous nous souhaitons
que lier des peines planchers appliquée
aux agresseurs de policiers et que c'est
poli ces délinquants soient condamnés
fermement et non pas un simple rappel à
la loi si vous laissez vous demander
justement voilà d'arrêter ce laxisme que
ça sonne que justement faire les efforts
soit renforcée après les attentats du 13
novembre
parce que il ya aussi beaucoup de
d'interpellations qui doivent êtres qui
te fait lille justement à ça et là vous
êtes donc plus de moyens a effectivement
l'année qui vient de se passer et tu est
une année très éprouvante pour les
forces de police nous n'avons en un an
sûrs quasiment aucun renfort
supplémentaire sur le département en
terme d'effectif
aucun moyen supplémentaire il ya une
superposition des missions comme vous
l'avez dit le plan vigipirate renforcé
la coop 21 l'état d'urgence il ya
beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires qui
sont accumulées par les fonctionnaires
et beaucoup de fatigue
alors justement comment fait-on voilà en
tant qu policiers pour assurer la
sécurité pour être efficace dans ce laps
de temps comme qui est assez long depuis
le 13 novembre à écouter en tout cas
quand je rencontre les collègues
effectivement c'est parfois difficile où
je n'ai pas vraiment de réponse à leurs
données quand certains passent les deux
fêtes de fin enfin les deux fêtes de fin
d'année au travail et ne voient pas
leurs familles c'est vrai que des fois
c'est compliqué
des vacances des congés effectivement
nous avons pour faire briller une baisse
une baisse due
du taux d'absence significative et du
coup il ya beaucoup de fatigue part dans
les forces de l'ordre il ya une
organisation qui a changé parce que si
l'effectif n'est pas renforcée
comment faites vous pour assurer le
roulement si vous devez assurer la
sécurité dans différents lieux en même
temps là si vous voulez les collègues
font ce qu'ils peuvent avec les moyens
qu'ils ont les moyens les effectifs
je suis sait pas trop comment vous
expliquez soul et nous ça fait un an
qu'ils aient eu les attentats de charlie
hebdo nous attendons des renforts sur le
département mais les seuls renforts
qu'on a vu en fin d'année ça à peine
compensé les départs qui a eu l'été
dernier donc si vous voulez à part le
courage et l'abnégation de mes collègues
on peut au niveau des moyens matériels
vous avez reçu rien rien rien du tout
c'est justement ce qu'on ce qu'on
déplore un on n'a même pas de date
concernant les livraisons de moyens
supplémentaires
donc les prix mois intervenants sont
toujours sans moyens balistique
on a on n'a pas de quoi faire face à une
attaque terroriste
concrètement justement vous parlez des
attentats de charlie hebdo donc le
triste anniversaire de ce béton taal
gueule donc cette semaine
ce qu'il va y avoir plus de précautions
qui vont être prises est ce que
justement aussi il faut peut-être la
part des citoyens faire plus attention
non rien rien ne change on est en état
d'urgence jusqu'à fin février
si vous voulez les effectifs policiers
de voie publique sont alors maximum si
vous voulez en termes de présence sur le
terrain on peut pas faire mieux
c'est à dire que les collègues quand je
les rencontre les effets sont deux les
patrouilles sont au complet on manque de
véhicules même parfois si l'état
d'urgence est prolongée après le 20
février sur les choses vont peut-être
changer pour vous vous l'espérez du
moins on l'espère on l'espère on attend
on attend les effectifs supplémentaires
nous savons qu'en janvier il ya à peu
près 1000 milles personnes qui sont
rentrées dans les écoles de police pour
nous renforcer sauf que la scolarité
dure un an donc si vous voulez les
effectifs les renforts vont arriver
quand justement voilà cette campagne qui
a été menée pour recruter a eu quand
même un certain effet il ya beaucoup de
gens qui soit au niveau de l'armée au
niveau de la peau ce qui se sont engagés
mais ça n'a pas vraiment d'effet pour
vous quel peut-être situation qui est le
m
vous attendez là pour que la situation
s'arrange qu'elle est demain en fin de
compte c'est vrai que nous on a tancé
ces renforts si l'on pourrait imaginer
pendant que des policiers de provence
viennent vous prêter main forte en ile
de france
non c'est l'organisation est assez
complexe
puis les collègues de province ont
également aussi beaucoup sollicités je
sais que les militaires viennent
beaucoup nous renforcer on a également
des réservistes qui viennent aider dans
certains commissariats mais c'est passé
on demande effectivement plus effectif
mais il faut du temps pour les former
est ce que justement voilà donc l'année
2016 commence fin sous des auspices plus
on part quand même de sécurité il faut
faire attention il ya des événements qui
vont changer ce que peut-être voilà
comme 21 il y avait beaucoup de sécurité
les gros événements comme ça doit être
plus organisés plus sécurité vous avez
des consignes en ce sens alors nous sur
soixante dix huit pour l'instant en fait
on envoie des effectifs ponctuellement
renfort c'est à dire que pour la coop 21
il ya des effectifs du choix 118 qui
sont partis en renfort comme va y avoir
certainement besoin de beaucoup de
renforts pour l'euro 2016
bon bah les effectifs qui partent en
renfort ne sont pas sur le département
donc effectivement est dans une
situation d'état d'urgence fait qu'on ne
souhaite pas évidemment mais qui se
passerait dans le département il est
vrai la possibilité voilà pour la police
d'intervenir rapidement
oui oui sauf que les collègues sont très
courageux et effectivement sont très
professionnels sauf que ont ils n'ont
pas les moyens là la drc peine direct
et comment réagir face à une attaque
terroriste voilà les collègues le savent
déjà cédé principes d'intervention qu'on
a comme de protéger le citoyen c'est
notre métier nous ce qu'on manque ces
deux moyens et il faudrait revoir
également le cadre de la légitime
défense filles dans les mesures qui ont
été mises en place à ce propos donc soit
les policiers municipaux qu'ils soient
armés ou que un policier puisse garder
son arme même quand il ne travaille pas
de prison civile vous voulez juger
comment penser que ça elles peuvent être
encore améliorés faire encore plus de
choses qui soient faites dans ce sens
exactement alliance police nationale
nous on se bat pour que le fonctionnaire
de police et le droit de porter son arme
peu importe sa position administrative
qu'il soit en congé
sur le trajet du travail et ça nous a
été autorisée la actuellement
exceptionnellement que durant l'état
d'urgence voilà donc fin février le
retour à la réglementation et le
policier devra remettre son son arme
dans l'armoire forte durant les
week-ends durant ce repos merci beaucoup
vu dans le calme d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et à présent tout autre sujet
mangues ananas on praline la bûche de
noël était bien la star des fêtes de fin
d'année pendant les vacances le service
jeunesse de trappes a même lancé pour la
première fois un concours de bûches de
noël destinés aux enfants ils étaient
une vingtaine âgés de 6 à 14 ans à
confectionner leur propre recette
au total quatre buts ont été réalisés un
jury devait les départager en fonction
d'une dizaine de critères le goût bien
évidemment mais aussi la couleur et
l'originalité une compétition mais avant
tout un moment convivial on écoute le
coordinateur de l'opération bruno hubert
ils se sont dits d'accord de joie pour
justement réalisés aussi bien donc leur
bouche avec la déco qui va avec et
vraiment il était on va dire motivés
pour
on va dire travailler à cette
réalisation que vous avez vu aujourd'hui
ils vont pouvoir vraiment déguster donc
la bûche à la fin donc c'est un moment
convivial avant tout avant même le
concours ce moment convivial pour eux
les élèves ont repris le chemin de
l'école vous le savez les vacances sont
finies mais certains ont décidé de
mettre leurs vacances à profit à
guyancourt pendant deux semaines la
ville organisé un stage de journalisme
dédiés aux jeunes
avec l'aide d'une journaliste
professionnel cinq jeunes passionnés ont
pu s'initier au monde des médias en
s'essayant à la rédaction d'un journal
un moyen également de mieux appréhender
l'information un sujet signé sephora
namani et camille lambert des devoirs de
vacances assez particulier pour ces
jeunes si corentin est là aujourd'hui
c'est pour participer à l'élaboration
d'un journal grâce à ce stage organisé
par la ville
cinq clients courtois ont pu découvrir
de l'intérieur le monde du journalisme
le cias cas stage parce que j'ai envie
de devenir toujours nice plus tard et
puis je pense que c'est une bonne
expérience déjà créé un magazine qu'on a
pu faire
puis de regarder comment on fait les
articles comme entendu les gens qui
étaient supposés apprendre à
hiérarchiser l'information manier les
sources et des différents types de
médias
les adolescents se sont pris au jeu en
s'essayant même à la radio sur marmite
fm
mais aujourd'hui place au bouclage du
journal le premier constat c'était aussi
la liberté d'expression qu'est ce que
c'est c'est aussi le fait de pouvoir
s'exprimer déjà et donc donner les
moyens à des jeunes dans la ville de
concours de pouvoir s'exprimer via le
journal via aussi la radio il ya l'idée
de travailler sur la solidarité avant
tout est donc dans la solidarité et la
citoyenneté
mais dans la citoyenneté il ya
l'expression il ya donc voilà les jeunes
sont saisis de tout ça et ça donne
quelque chose
extrêmement intéressants grâce à l'aide
2 sandra journalistes professionnels ces
jeunes ont décliné le thème de la
solidarité sous plusieurs angles en
évitant les pièges
c'était vraiment important pour moi de
bien leur expliquer que oui il faut
croire ce qu'on voit mais faut vérifier
il faut savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui
est pas vrai et cocher un peu partout
pas s'arrêter au premier article
convient extrêmes le premier jour
c'était vraiment leur expliquer le
métier du journalisme et après c'était
donc voilà deux créer ce magazine où il
était vraiment acteur de a à z c'est
qu'on choisit les couleurs c'est aux
croisés les artix un magazine d'une
quinzaine de pages que les guyancourt
toi pourront découvrir d'ici une dizaine
de jours
tirage papier ou internet reste encore à
définir le mode de diffusion et vous le
savez chaque commune organise c'était
appétant d'activités périscolaires et
leur contenu alors certains sont plus
originaux que d'autres à l'image de ceux
proposés par la ville de coignières à
l'école marcel pagnol
nous en parlons avec sephora namani dans
la première chronique culturelle de
l'année
bonsoir sephora mais voilà les gars
merci vous également alors oui
exactement vous le disiez en fait les 24
élèves de cm1 de l'école de coignières
de marcel pagnol ont la chance en fait
de découvrir le fonctionnement de
l'appareil photographique réflexe tous
les réglages qu'il faut mettre en
pratique pour réaliser des nets et des
flous justement en jouant avec la
profondeur de champ et on regarde tout
de suite les détails avec camille
paillardes enseignante à l'école marcel
pagnol de coignières on a monté un
projet p a qu'un projets éducatifs
artistiques et culturelles sur la
photographie parce que c'est un domaine
qui est inconnu des enfants qui apprend
aux enfants bas à se servir d'un
appareil photo reflex a du coup
découvrir leur milieu proche d'une autre
façon a observé d'une autre façon et du
coup nous en classe on travaille en
histoire des arts sur les grands
photographes sur les grands courants sur
la technique pour qu'ils aient du coup
quelque chose un petit peu complet alors
c'est fort à cet atelier permet de
développer quelle qualité chez l'enfant
alors hormis bien sûr en fait de savoir
maîtriser les différents réglages comme
l'iso
l'ouverture et la vitesse ça permet
également aux enfants de développer leur
sens de l'observation tout en apprenant
à regarder différemment leur
environnement et puis ça leur apprend
également à participer à un projet
collectif
alors comment se déroule comment se
décompose ces ateliers de façon très
pratique alors donc le groupe les 24
élèves sont divisés en deux groupes l'un
est sur le terrain pour apprendre une
forme de mise en pratique de ce qu'ils
apprennent en classe qui est plus
théorique et c'est leur professeur de
classe qui leur enseignent les cours
d'histoire de l'art
donc là on a la vraie lumière rembrandt
on peut comparer entre la photo et la
peinture
d'accord maintenant on va observer la
lumière rembrandt sur des photographies
là c'est une photo est ce qu'on a ici le
triangle rembrandt est ce que tu vois le
triangle de lumière ici on le voit bien
là il est matérialisé justement est-ce
qu'on a les faits clairs obscurs
reda oui on a une partie du visage qui
est éclairée et l'autre qui est sont
donc là est ce que le photographe a
réussi à créer la lumière rembrandt
oui et vous l'avez compris donc pendant
ce temps là l'autre partie de la classe
était sur le terrain avec un photographe
professionnel alors super par contre les
mutants droite
par contre là dans popeye
il n'a pas des chaussures moi ce que je
te conseille c'est carrément de foot et
qui s'implante pas brisé tu fais un plan
plus serré comme ça d'accord ou alors
tout le monde entier à chaque cours on a
vu une une notion différente d'accord et
en fait on l'a travaillé pendant le
cours dont le premier cours on a parlé
des iso avec plus ou moins de lumière à
l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur d'une
régulation publique de l'appareil ça ils
ont bien intégré le court dernier pardon
pour notre avis la vitesse non non non
on a travaillé un petit peu tout le
monde connaît flash à la télé donc je
leur montre un peu comment je vais faire
flasher faisant disparaître le co peine
de la photo comme en règle et donc du
coup ça nous a permis de travailler
différentes notions techniques par
l'amusement
alors cette fois on voit le photographe
par les 10 aux deux vitesses en cm1 on a
9 10 ans était un peu trop jeune pour
aborder des concepts qui squattent assez
technique alors c'est vrai que j'étais
moi même la première surprise c'est
assez surprenant
on sent vraiment que les enfants
comprennent ce qu'ils font et surtout
qu'ils aiment ça et après comment rec 2
les appareils photo j'ai appris comment
fêter des photos comment comment on
allume et les appareils photo et du coup
main j'aime bien la photo grâce à les
réglages les modes manuels et les
réglages et et ciseaux et les réglages
telle ouverture ou du focal et on a
après l'ouverture c'est du studio qu'est
ce que tu aimes dans son sac et des
photos faire des photos m'amuser avec
mes amis travailler avec mes amis et la
motivation supplémentaire également pour
eux c'est qu'ils partent deux semaines
en classe de neige en janvier avec leurs
intervenants en photographe photographie
pardon et tous les matins ils seront
invités à expérimenter différentes
prises de vues des portraits des
paysages à la neige et sera organisée
une restitution fin février courant mars
avec les plus beaux clichés des enfants
effectivement c'est une belle motivation
de partir au ski sont faire des photos
merci ces forums on vous retrouve
mercredi pour un nouveau numéro de
kiosques mais de l'année exactement je
préparais les belles surprises j'espère
alors oui
va parler cinéma on va parler magie et
illusionnisme et musique
d'accord elle vient très bien maintenant
nous allons parler sport ils l'ont fait
le club demande dernière équipe lilloise
encore en course pour la coupe de france
a réussi l'exploit de se qualifier pour
les 16e de finale de la compétition en
battant le stade briochin le score 2
buts à 0 retour sur cette qualification
le reportage est signée mutuelle et demi
d'euros et fanny bourdon une victoire
historique le fc mantois 78 club de cfa
a réussi l'exploit de se hisser en
seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france en battant difficilement sur son
terrain le stade briochin une équipe de
cfa2 le score 2 buts à 0 avec des
réalisations de francis massampu et
brûlent auprès rats dans les arrêts de
jeu une qualification au forceps sur le
match on peut pas se vanter d'avoir été
au dessus au dessus on a eu la chance
d'ouvrir le score au bon moment de la
partie à prendre a subi mais bon comme
ce qui compte c'est de passer des
regrets d'avoir encaissé ce but là parce
que finalement ils nous marquent le but
sur leur seule demi-occasion c'est même
pas une véritable occasion donc le
regret il est là félicitations mantois
c'est eux qui ont gagné sont passés même
si on peut considérer qu'on a été
meilleurs que sur ce match là mais au
final c'est moi qui seront 16e donc les
citations
avec cette victoire le fc mantois écrit
l'une des plus belles pages de son
histoire depuis sa création en 1994 le
club n'avait jamais dépassé le stade des
32e de finale de la coupe de france
c'est sur ce que les gens vont retenir
c'est la qualification
même dans 10 ans on pourra dire qu'on a
fait un seizième prêt pour ce qu'ils ont
vécu c'est vrai que c'était difficile en
16e de finale le dernier représentant et
vit loin de cette coupe de france
pourrait recevoir à la maison des clubs
de ligue 1 comme le paris saint germain
monaco lyon ou encore marseille
ce qu'on souhaitait déjà c'était
atteindre les seizièmes de finale
maintenant qu'on est ont conduit et
pourquoi pas une ligue 1 et pourquoi pas
un voisin attendant le psg mais ça c'est
le souhait de n'importe quel club en
france
réponse lundi 4 janvier à 19h30 pour le
tirage les supporteurs ne demande qu'à
rêver
le début des années 2000 16 leur a bien
réussi car le match a eu lieu le samedi
1er janvier 2016 et justement en ce
début d'année il est de tradition de
prendre de bonnes résolutions alors se
mettre au sport voyages et arrêter de
fumer ou rester zen quelles sont celles
qui reviennent le plus souvent à quelles
sont vos bonnes résolutions de l'année
2016 c'est ce que nous vous avons
demandé
regardez quand on se rappelle tout les
événements de l'année 2015 et notamment
ceux de 13 novembre sans oublier de
janvier 2015 si avec charlie je crois
que c'est des choses qu'on n'oubliera
jamais est ce qu'il faut souhaiter c'est
conviés dans un monde de paix une
meilleure année que l'année dernière
obligatoirement tout le monde le
souhaite je pense et puis et puis de
façon ça peut être que mieux
bon j'avais la trouille c'est le plus
important la santé et que ça se passe un
peu mieux que 2015 surtout du bonheur de
la santé et puis la paye sur deux mais
vivre en paix la paix le calme la
sérénité voilà elle tout le bonheur et
puisque nous évoquions les voeux mais
aussi les révolutions pour l'année 2016
sachez que certains maires ont décidé de
ne pas organiser les l'heure pas de
cérémonie de voeux à saint cyr par
exemple le maire les républicains évoqué
des mesures supplémentaires trop
coûteuses afin d'assurer la sécurité en
cette période d'état d'urgence
le préfet a en effet demandé de limiter
les manifestations publiques
la ville entend ainsi réaliser des
économies alors que les dotations de
l'état sont en diminution pour 2016 les
villes de poissy de fontenay le fleury
ou encore la ville socialiste de trappes
ont pris une décision similaire
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec michael
elle me d'euros pour la reprise du ctu
sport la première de l'année à ne pas
rater quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau numéro du journal
je vous souhaite donc une très bonne
année mais aussi une très belle soirée